[Музика]
привіт усім мене звуть Анна. Сьогодні я
вчитель англійської мови,
ми продовжимо нашу
подорож навколо світу та
англомовних країн, тому ми
вже були у Великобританії, а сьогодні
ми збираємося  до США Я впевнений, що
ви багато чого чули про
США, тож тепер ви почуєте кілька
цікавих фактів про цю країну, а
після цього ми збираємося відвідати два
штати цієї країни, тож давайте продовжимо
нашу подорож так  США Сполучені Штати
Америки, тож він складається із штатів, а
їх 50, але що
цікавого в цій країні, то
першим фактом, найбільш густонаселеним
містом США є Нью-Йорк
, за яким, безсумнівно, йдуть інші
два міста: Лос-Анджелес і
Чикаго, другий факт:
Джеймс і Мері - найпопулярніші
імена, які дають у Сполучених
Штатах, тож чи можете ви уявити, що Джеймс і
Мері ходять навколо вас у США,
їх багато,
так що т  третій факт, що американці споживають 3
мільярди піци на рік, ви можете собі уявити,
що це майже половина людей,
які живуть у світі, але в піци
четвертий факт є офіційна
гра камінь-ножиці-папір Ліга
в США,
що таке камінь-  ножиці-папір ви, мабуть,
знаєте ту гру українською, яка
помітна по бороді, але це
англійською, так що
це гра, яка насправді має офіційний
спосіб, ви можете собі уявити, що це справжній
вид спорту і ось воно в  США і
п'ятий факт, останній Гаваї є
найновішим із 50 штатів Америки,
тож тепер давайте перейдемо до Гаваїв, які
насправді є островом, і це
штат Сполучених Штатів Америки, який
є єдиним штатом, який розташований  на
острові на кількох островах, звісно, тому ці
строви та маєток Гаваї ро
ташовані в Тихому океані, то
у єдині ми  штат, розташований за межами
Північної Америки, і єдиний острівний штат
– Гаваї. На слайді ви можете побачити
зображення, які насправді ілюструють
речі, які більшість людей асоціюють з
Гаваями, щоб ви могли побачити, як люди танцюють,
і це традиційний гавайський
танець, який вони носять у спідницях.
це також традиційні гавайські спідниці,
вони носять квіткові вінки,
вони також традиційні, ви можете
побачити кокос на березі моря на
Гавайських островах, і
я здивований цими фактами.
дуже відома людина, яка
народилася на Гавайських островах,
тож давайте почнемо вибирати правильні
варіанти, щоб завершити історію оповідання
, коли світило сонце, коли
Бетані Гамільтон прибула на пляж
гарного ранку на Гаваях, але через
кілька годин підліток, якого служив, займався серфінгом
з моря, коли на неї напала акула,
і вона на диво втратила ліву руку,
болото Бетані пливло назад.
пляж однією рукою, і коли вона
плавала, вона сказала іншим серфінгістам
вибратися з води, тому тепер наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб
вибрати правильні варіанти, оскільки ви можете
бачити найгірші в скорописі наші
варіанти, тому нам потрібно вибрати той, який
здається  щоб бути правильним, давайте почнемо
з першого речення,
коли Бетані Гамільтон прибула на пляж, то давайте почнемо з першого речення, коли Бетані Гамільтон прибула на
пляж, тож
ми описуємо обставини,
тому в цьому випадку нам обов’язково потрібно
буде використати минуле безперервне відьми
сяяли  тож сонце світило, коли
Бетані прибула, так багато було з
місцевою Bethany pre Helana plush
друге речення зараз, але через кілька
годин молодий підліток служив або займався
серфінгом у морі, коли акула напала на її
раду, впевнений ботамо сер fucka
václav Allah's Maire  : inane Nepali
Akula так було, що безперервна дія, як
вона плавала, так, ми можемо припустити,
що тут ми також виберемо
двигун, і ось варіант, який нам
потрібно  оберіть, що він займався серфінгом, але через
кілька годин вони з підлітком займалися серфінгом
і бачили, коли акула напала на неї,
а останнє речення дивовижним чином Bethany
swamp або плавала назад на
пляж однією рукою, тому ми фактично говоримо
про завершену дію, яку вона
впоралася.  щоб зробити це mooooo нижня частина
збереження ідеальна кнопка сама
найнижча Роберта - мама я з Шибата
незаймана скриня Манолі, яка пройшла через болото,
тому ось це історія про
Бетані, яка плавала і займалася серфінгом на
Гаваях і її руку вкусила акула
так що вона насправді дуже відома і
дуже успішна серфінгістка зараз, і тепер ви
знаєте дивовижну історію цієї дівчини, тому
зараз ми збираємося в інший штат
США, ми збираємося в Колорадо, ми збираємося
відвідати місто Денвер  там
ви почуєте ще одну дивовижну історію про
іншу дивовижну людину, насправді ви
почуєте навіть про двох дивовижних людей, тому
Денвер
Колорадо США Денвер є
столицею штату Колорадо, у ньому є  більшість
населення в усьому штаті
розташована на схід від переднього
хребта Скелястих гір. Б’юся об заклад, ви чули
про них Скелясті гори, одна з
найвідоміших гір дикого
заходу США, хто не чув про це,
напевно, бачив  і чув про деякі
західні фільми, і насправді Колорадо
Денвер
був головним містом, де відбувалися події в той
час. О, Джетт
Денвер, Колорадо сказав, що, пане транспортний засіб,
Морріс поранив Алекса Паділлу, гомонка, нада
como de como z'ha'dum О,
поки на заході Золота лихоманка  почалося тут
у 1858 році, тому це був рік, коли все
почалося добре, тепер, оскільки ви знаєте щось
про Денвер, Колорадо, ми збираємося
почути про щось дивовижне, що
трапилося з людьми в цьому місті, наше завдання
— вибрати правильні варіанти ще
раз, щоб завершити  історія історії - це
був звичайний день в аеропорту Денвера,
але коли рейс 455 був знятий,
пасажири побачили вогонь з
вікна, відразу ж капітан літака
зрозумів, що інж.  інес не спрацювала,
ми займаємося тверкінгом і зверталися за допомогою по радіо,
поки пасажири бігли
до передніх виходів. Марія Гарза
витягнула свою дочку через вікно
біля Вейна, тому це
дивовижна історія, яка сталася в Денвері
кілька років тому  а тепер давайте виберемо
правильні варіанти в реченнях,
почнемо з першого речення, тому
в аеропорту Денвера був звичайний день, але
коли дружину рейсу 405 зняли,
пасажири побачили або побачили вогонь
з вікна, тому вони насправді побачили
вогонь.  що ми маємо сказати, тому що це
була одноразова завершена дія, а
з другого речення відразу
ж капітан літака зрозумів, що
двигуни не працюють або не працюють,
тож ми описуємо обставини
чи ми описуємо дію, яка
щойно сталася  ну ми тут описуємо
обставини, нам потрібно буде
сказати, що двигуни ми працюємо і працюємо,
поки пасажири біжать або ми біжимо
до передніх виходів Марія витягнула
її дитина через вікно через
вікно, тому пасажири, яких вони щойно
бігали або бігали деякий час,
добре біг – це діяльність, яка займає
трохи більше часу, ніж просто встати,
і ви закінчили
добре бігати – це безперервна дія  тут,
тому нам потрібно буде сказати, що поки
пасажири бігали нормально, а тепер у
вас є питання, щоб подумати,
яка історія, на вашу думку, є найбільш
цікавою для мене особисто,
історії Бетані є більш дивовижними, тому тепер
перейдемо до граматики і насправді  ми
збираємося говорити про те, що тривалі
часи, єдиний, про який ми будемо
говорити сьогодні, це минулий безперервний
час минулого разу, коли ми говорили про минулий простий
час дії, які насправді щойно
відбулися і вони закінчилися в
минулому, зараз ми йдемо  щоб розповісти про
час, який описує тривалі тривалі
дії в минулому, давайте подивимося
на дошку past continue, ось
структура того, як ми формуємо речення
в минулому con  безперервний зараз двері Стів
з'явився про структурну
форму ерекції минулого безперервного виробництва,
яке, я бачу, ви прийшли до хору
Тобермана, магазин тако навпроти
спроби Avenue G, враховуючи підхід Пехлеві,
акомпануйте ho ciaossu Manolo
Doha D Prado Німеччина, тож ось що є
минуле безперервне  бо давайте подивимося
на структуру, нам потрібно, щоб дієслово бути
у двох формах у минулому простому
це або was або were це залежить
від людини, про яку ми говоримо,
тому з ah he she it we use was with you
we they we  використання were давайте подивимося
на позитивні речення та приклади, які
я грав ви грали негативне
речення він не грав ми не
грали, тому, порівнюючи позитивні
та заперечні речення в минулому
безперервному, ми можемо помітити, що зробити
негативні речення, які ми просто повинні
додати частинку not ojos de tahuapoa Оперативні дії Ріти
та Регіни мимо простого
nom not hidden approach to the data
charge can separate Savannah just go
дочка дозвіл високої лави GS
був остерігайтеся мій модем Шабату я просто
не можу
о, бідний пропустити шлях для мене емоції, коли він
забив Shweta Oh Jerry baccha Mona
Dorsey оцінка Вірджинія не була підставою
Питання створюються за допомогою дієслова to
be ще раз  was або ми на
початку, тому ми почнемо наші питальні
речення з використання was or we're in the
front position Давайте подивимося на
приклади, як вона грала, коли вони
грали, не забувайте про знак питання
у запитаннях  тож, і якщо нам знадобиться
розділ із короткою відповіддю М ні, він знав би,
що трапляється дивне, може бути свідком
Патанії, коли модератор
кімчі Нам так, вона була
ні, вона не була бомбою так вони були ні
вони не були такими  це
структура безперервного минулого, ми знову використовуємо його,
щоб говорити про тривалі дії в минулому,
тому минуле безперервне також використовується для
різних дій.
в  минуле,
наприклад, о 8 годині вчора я
читав «Хроніки Нарнії»,
другу книгу, яку ми можемо використовувати безперервне минуле,
щоб описати сцени в історії
або описі це був чудовий день,
світило сонце, співали птахи
і все  була настільки гарною, що
третя, що ми можемо говорити про активність,
яка була в процесі, коли інша
коротша діяльність трапилася закінчилася,
її перервали ми використовуємо минуле
безперервне я читав книгу, коли
почув, як хтось стукає у двері
номер чотири, і як це часто буває  вживається
з безперервним минулим під час або коли я
йшов вулицею, я побачив Джейн,
і дієслова стану останнього вживання
зазвичай не вживаються в безперервному, ми
можемо сказати, що мені подобалися Сімпсони, коли я
був підлітком, але ми не можемо сказати, що я був
схожий  у Сімпсонах, тому дієслова стану
не можна використовувати в безперервних формах, а
тепер давайте попрактикуємося, ми збираємося
виконати вправу, щоб відпрацьовувати
минулий тривалий час, наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб скласти
речення, які ми використовуємо в p  як безперервно, наше
завдання — розкрити дужки та поставити
дієслова у правильні форми, давайте
подивимося на перше речення Джон грати в
теніс о 3 годині завтра кожна тварина
Hawara no protest show Джон водив
бутанський otra taeho donítö завтра
bottom of progeria  Kavitha Valley Південна
бетонна природа Омаха не більше веселий
найдешевший безперервний NASA бичачий був
показаний протилежний theta або плавати
фільм під назвою Stover і що було не
пропустіть kasha вологи Джон грав у
теніс о 3:00 номер 2 mr.  і
місіс  зелений не їсть у їдальні,
коли сталося вбивство, тому ми повинні
сказати, що вони нічого не робили,
коли сталася інша діяльність. Optima
total bottom up Radhika beam
продюсер Пехлеві Уоллес Кулі в Cydia Tripoli
Zepa chesty AG e para valley про
простату або геном no  дитина без постулату a
не їсть з минулим безперервною формою пакета
mr.  і місіс  green that's множина, тому
є багато людей, буде принаймні двоє,
нам знадобиться дієслово were so were not
eating in the dining room ми можемо
скоротити форму дієслова тут, щоб ми могли
використовувати коротку форму where and where та
eating in the dining  кімната номер три я
пишу листи цілий день
вчора Чавес Даніель можлива
нерухомість Наташа процес Кесада і його
комова
майя міджіта перепустка триває, тому я
писав листи цілий день учора
номер чотири що ви робите, коли я телефонував
учора, тому ми хочемо знати, які
безперервні дії ця людина  was doing,
коли ми їх знайшли, тому для цього для
цієї дії нам потрібно буде поставити дієслово
do у безперервну форму, а оскільки ми
запитуємо про вас, нам знадобиться
форма дієслова to be to be were what
where you doing  коли я вчора знайшов
номер п'ять,
вона дивилася телевізор, коли це трапилося,
якщо сільський чоловік, який доставляє Уркела,
каже, що долари нам потрібно поставити
допоміжне дієслово was на
початку речення, оскільки це питання
Лікар, але я знаю, що Мустафа Мустафа не був
папугою Томо СкарДжо Маша,
коли це сталося, вона дивилася телевізор,
номер шість, ми переглядаємо весь день
у бібліотеці, мій заступник голови, який
тахваллі вгору потаро, буде
обертатися, тому перегляд потрібно ввести
в безперервний  форма якщо це ми так ми
говоримо про нас множина форма була
б тоді ми повинні будемо сказати, що
ми переглядали весь день у
бібліотеці зверніть увагу, що буква е
в кінці дієслова revise
зникла, а замість неї ми
використали ing і Dane і номер сім
останній тут ми вип'ємо кави, коли ми
почули новини по радіо про
комічну новели з пачулі Джемми Паули, тепер
Роджер знову у нас перервана
дія, нам потрібно використовувати минуле
безперервне, і ми
ще раз поговоримо про множину, тож після того, як ми вживаємо
were та ing, форму здоров’я, тож ми
пили каву, тож ось
і вправа, а тепер,
Чак, чого ви навчилися на
сьогоднішньому уроці, а тепер давайте  Підсумуйте
все, що ми дізналися, тож тут у
вас є три запитання до
змісту сьогоднішнього уроку, давайте перевіримо те, що
ви дізналися питання номер один, у
якому океані знаходиться штат Гаваї,
чи пам’ятаєте ви, що одне з моїх
магістрів показує вам, що це  щось мовчазне,
тому насправді ми говоримо про
Тихий океан, це правильно. Друге
питання Денвер Колорадо розташований
поблизу гір, які гори,
які гори, як назва цих
гір, ви можете побачити зірки, ймовірно
, це щось про рок-зірки, і
так, ви"  я зрозумів, що це Скелясті
гори Скелясті гори Денвер
Колорадо розташовано саме там, і
третє питання, які дві форми
дієслова to be do ми використовуємо в минулому
тривалому часі, правда, це
було, і ми так, хлопці, дякую
дуже за вашу увагу,
я сподіваюся, що ви добре і наполегливо попрацювали, і
ми побачимося наступного разу,
дякую і до побачення
[Музика]